général dominique trinquent ancien chef
de la mission militaire française à
l'onu bonsoir général trinquant merci
d'être avec nous ce soir sur arte france
alors une pandémie qui entravent une
opération extérieure française
est-ce que c'est déjà arrivé de mémoire
de militaires alors c'est un petit peu
faux de dire que la pandémie entrave une
opération extérieure
l'opération de vous parler est une
opération de formation en irak et comme
vous le savez l'irak est pas très loin
de l'iran est donc aujourd'hui le
retrait des forces françaises en irak
fait suite à une méfiance que nous avons
sur toute la situation dans cette région
donc si vous voulez autant on pourrait
en parler si vous parliez de retraite
par exemple de la zone du sahel dont il
n'est absolument pas question autant une
une opération de formation en irak ça
une connotation un peu différente
combien de militaires vont être
rapatriés à est-ce qu'ils vont être mis
en quarantaine et qu'elles vont être
leur rôle alors le le chiffre annoncé de
200 probablement 100 instructeurs et
sans qu'ils sont en soutien
je n'ai pas d'information sur leur
retrait normalement toutes forces
françaises qu'il ait retiré d'un théâtre
se passe dans ce qu'on appelle un sas de
décompression d'une semaine ou quinze
jours donc ça va probablement être le
cas cette fois-ci simplement est-ce que
ça va être une quarantaine et est-ce
qu'il va y avoir des tests qui vont être
faits auprès d'eux je ne le sais pas
mais en tout cas c'est environ 200 5 200
hommes et qui passeront par un sas de
décompression
alors c'est un retrait 1 en raison
forcément des de la crise
sanitaire est ce que les soldats sont
censés revenir en irak
plus tard alors la mission de formation
en irak comme vous le savez est très
compromise elle a été compromise une
première fois après les actions
américaines les irakiens avaient demandé
le retrait l'opération
l'opération est revenu il n'est pas il
n'est pas impossible qu'elle qu'elle
revienne
ça va être une négociation entre le
gouvernement irakien et le gouvernement
français je le répète il s'agit d'une
opération de formation il s'agit pas
d'une opération de combat
nous sommes bien d'accord mais les
troupes présentes en irak forme est donc
un les militaires locaux vous l'avez dit
quelles conséquences pour la lutte
contre le groupe etat islamique et dans
la région
c'est forcément en irak au moins un
sujet de préoccupation je rappelle qu'il
ya par ailleurs des forces spéciales
françaises qui sont plutôt en syrie et
qui elle n'est pas question de les
rapatrier
donc toute opération de formation qui
s'interrompt est un est un sujet mais
encore une fois c'est une négociation
entre le gouvernement irakien et le
gouvernement français le chef de l'état
a annoncé hier le lancement de
l'opération résilience qui reste encore
un peu floue en bois se l'avouer on
comprend en tout cas que l'armée ira là
où l'aide se fait sentir dans l'océan
atlantique notamment pour aider à la
guyane et les antilles concrètement à
quoi va ressembler cette cette aide
alors je sais pas si elle est floue pour
moi pour vous pour moi elle ne l'est pas
du tout le premier point c'est un
soutien médical le soutien médical qu'on
a vu en france déjà et qui est prolongé
comme le toner le porte hélicoptères qui
était intervenu en corse par
l'intervention du mistral qui est dans
le serré indiens et qui va vers la
réunion et du dixmude qui va aller vers
les antilles ça c'est le premier volet
le deuxième volet c'est un soutien
logistique
il va y avoir besoin d'un renfort
logistique en particulier pour
l'acheminement de matériel les armées
françaises vont pouvoir le faire
le troisième volet est un ce volet de
protection comme vous le savez les
militaires ne peuvent pas et il faut
bien distinguer sa de sentinelle
l'opération senti là elle va continuer
et elle c'est une mission de lutte
contre le terrorisme alors que la
protection dont nous parlons c'est le
remplacement d'un certain nombre de
forces de sécurité auprès de sites
sensibles de façon à libérer des
effectifs pour assurer le contrôle du
confinement qui a été décrétée par le
gouvernement
est ce que les militaires aient tous les
corps d'armées sont formés à gérer ce
genre de situation une épidémie non
évidemment que ça n'est pas et
d'ailleurs les militaires ne sont pas
appelés à gérer l'épidémie
le service de santé des armées oui les
trois bateaux dont nous avons parlé
effectivement puisque ce sont des
bateaux qui peuvent être transformés en
en bateau hôpital
quant aux deux autres formations dont
j'ai parlé la logistique
il s'agit du transport donc ça que ce
soit de santé ou autre chose il n'y a
pas de difficultés les quant à la garde
de points sensibles qu'il y ait une
épidémie une pandémie ou pas ça ne
change rien au sujet général train quand
le confinement va être allongée dans les
jours qui viennent c'est une certitude
est ce que dans cette situation qui est
complètement inédite
on peut imaginer la ramée dans nos rues
peut-être après un durcissement s'il y
avait des mesures de confinement
pour l'instant je ne vois pas les
mesures qui ont été prises annoncé par
le président de la république en parlant
de l'opération résilience sont des
mesures déjà importante
mais je rappelle que la mesure là
l'action principale des armées
c'est d'abord l'action contre le
terrorisme en particulier aux sa belle
avec plus de 5000 hommes qui sont
déployés là-bas
l'opération sentinelle qui est dans les
rues aujourd'hui effectivement b contre
le terrorisme en revanche y revient aux
forces de sécurité c'est-à-dire poli
gendarmerie d'agir pour le confinement
les militaires n'ont aucune capacité
pour intervenir dans le cas du
confinement en particulier parce qu'ils
n'ont pas de d'actions légales à avoir
sur les citoyens
donc je pense que simplement l'extension
de la garde d'un certain nombre de sites
que ce soit des sites nucléaires que ce
soit décide de transport à des
militaires pourraient avoir lieu
la coordination se fera entre les
préfets des régions et les généraux
comment dans les régions militaires et
c'est à ce niveau là que sera la
coordination comme ils le savent la
faire puisque la coopération et
quotidiennes entre ces autorités
merci beaucoup général dominique
fringant d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
je rappelle que vous êtes ancien chef de
la mission militaire française à l'onu
merci beaucoup